underway at T-Mobile tonight and Alex panelo
into the offensive end Jonathan Marsh is so
looking race job blocked Away by Drew dowy out
High Carlson let a rip and a save talet good
look for William Carlson no goals in his last
four his longest drought of the Season into
the offensive zone he and Jonathan Marcus will
reunited tangelo will wrist shot on on a save
talbet and Hutton trying to play it down the
glass that jumped the glass gabov Banks it up
ahead and leerer plays it across to arur C EV
and Michael up ice against katar and the kings
are one of the better offensive teams in the
league they're third in offense in the NHL iel
scores off the posted end Jack anel snaps home
number 16 and the golden knights with the the
lead we won't see a much better play shot than
that stones in front great cross scene pass by
barev and eel just allowed time and space gets
his head up picks his spot and rips it posted
in love side look at that shot by eel perfectly
placed as the Golden Heights grabbed the one-
nothing lead Anheim it's a tough League to
Chase game in and it will come out get the
lead in this one barriers pass Puck towards
the net by du and Thompson well a couple of
good stops in tight and the pass right
between the legs of Dow's able to keep
it in Anderson keeps it moving to K and back
to Anderson Kar throws it on net save made by
Thompson C holding R shot tip and a save Thompson
oh Thompson's been sharp in the open opening 13
and 1/2 minutes W Zips it across for ha outed
little backwards in on grun in front the Kosar
they got turned away by talut and then talot
handles the Martinez wrist shot six shots coming
his way he's been able to pick up said the best
chance was DUIs in tight bouncing Puck and Carlson
denied by talet extend the lead Marshall get it to
the front it bounces over the Stick of Deno little
Chance by Carlson and watch Conor he gets the
chance and it's a bit of a bouncing Puck I'm not
sure if it caught to no stick I think it just kind
of you can tell the reaction of pul in by gabov
long a wrist shot in a body and to the corner
it's Martinez Matt Roy with a steal Stevenson
to the net at tble with a huge stop great read by
Martinez finds Stevenson in the middle speed up
the ice G able to poke that puck ahead Stevenson
keeps his Lane his stride he gets in all alone
great chance to extend the lead talbet came up
with the save so Gams have scored five goals
in each of their last two games a win before the
Christmas break over Calgary and a win last night
over San Jose golden kns are the only goal of this
period Carlson a wrist shot and a blocker save
talin up ice Nick W to Brett Howen throws
it on net and a routine glove save for Cam
talber and now Matt Roy kopar by field down
the wing throws it on net stick save Thompson
rebound to gabov Michael right near the net
and McNab to amadio off his skate Dori with
some speed with amadio on the rush amadio to scor
Michael amario from Pavo Doria it's two nothing
Vegas good break up again great pick up little
cross and drop aaro that creat separation and
amio just continues his line to the net gets a
great little back pass from dorf and how about
that finish as AO protects the puck leans in and
able to roof that over the left arm of talit great
goal by Michael a lazat and and now dowy off
to lazat runstrom in deep dowy across Anderson
wrist shot GL down by Thompson couldn't squeeze
it theala circling Roy out top of the wrist shot
deflected wide abof and Thompson holds title on
the short Side wiom open Ice drops it off for
stone the trailer is ha with a wrist shot blocked
over the net tangelo up the wing and iel looking
to get it out bouncing put to kopar a big saake
Thompson nothing lead for the golden knights here
in the second Logan Thompson best sa of the game
on Andre Kar shoves it around the wall for Howen
now White Cloud turns down the wing carries
it in deep puts it towards the net to going
to stick on it pops in the air and W keeps it in
how two white cloud long wrist shots steered aside
by talin Arthur CF trying to protect the puck ww
there white cloud open out top with a wrist shot
and a glum stve tell he'll hold it by Field behind
the net chips it around for Kee as we hit seven
minutes to go in the second golden kns with a goal
in each of the first two periods is Ria tap score
and Kar the top of the graas deflects it home
and he has the Kings on the board and this puck
just kind of goes through everybody watch the
bodies in front but it's going to find its way
right to copar at the side of the net a great
point shot pass and a little deflection from
Kopitar off to the left of Thompson good shift
here by the gold LS great shift by Jonathan Mar
cter over the LA line driving wide on calab
drags it in Around the Net he it in front
score William Carlson on a beautiful setup from
Paul conter and the golden knights back up by
two Carter get the puck along the wall will slow
then speeds it up and here Power Kia quick little
change up head up great Carlson as he finds the
open Lane perfect pass and a quick finish under
the pads at T but as Carlson picks up his 15
and the Golden Heights regain the two- goal
lead Stevenson DF in a mtio up front for the
golden knights Martinez and ha on defense down
Loria trying to feed it to Stevens they'll got it
on n and talat kicked it out suit of the puck he
showed Michael amadio the intermission what a
great stick he has another example on England
gets in inside position steals the puck dor for
Stevenson Stevenson doesn't get much on that
as Doria finds him gets the shot away dubis kind
of stick on Stick check as bounces and brunstrom
drags it to behind the net and now kopar more back
to kopar who has the king's goal Moore scores on
the base of the circle Trevor Moore with his team
leading 17th La within one with 159 to go he's
having a terrific season watches Thompson goes
down there's the shot right up over that right
shoulder a lot of room up there as he puts it
upstairs Kings with the heat here late
looking for the game tying goal and F
with a drive blocked by mcnf second
chance tonight by Thompson everywhere
laying down in front of the golden
kns doing whatever they can here
late the with 5 Seconds gains the
Line pass across doesn't connect and
that will do it the golden knights
with a three to win over the Kings